la commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme le conseil national
des barreaux et l'association avocats
sans frontières france interpelle à
nouveau les autorités françaises en jeu
le rapatriement des femmes et enfants de
djihadistes retenu en syrie après le
lancement il ya un mois par une
cinquantaine de personnalités d'une
campagne de parrainage à l'intention de
ces mineurs les avocats et un
parlementaire ont tenu une conférence de
presse hier pour dénoncer les conditions
de vie extrêmes dans lesquelles vivent
les quelques 200 enfants et 80 femmes
dans des concurrents du nord-est syrien
selon un rapport de l'oms j'essaye de
trine 2 children soixante deux mineurs
sont décédés depuis le début de l'année
on en parle avec danielle babin elle est
avocate spécialisée en droit des
étrangers
bonjour daniel va bien merci de répondre
à nos questions et matin organisé sans
délais le rapatriement en france des
enfants et des femmes de nationalité
française c'est ce que demande le groupe
d'avocats et de parlementaires en tant
qu'avocate est ce que vous estimez cette
requête juridiquement faisable
oui tout à fait je vous remercie déjà de
nous donner l'opportunité de partager ce
sujet délicat avec vous oui je pense que
c'est une exigence dans leur requête
formulée par à la fois
l'un
la commission nationale des droits de
l'homme et le cnv qui est quand même le
conseil national des barreaux avec un
collectif de confrères qui sont
directement intéressés par ce sujet
je pense que cette requête est légitime
et elle est faisable c'est une question
de volonté politique
voilà la situation des enfants
mineurs et de leurs invendus ou moins
pour ceux qui sont identifiés comme
étant des enfants français nécessite un
regard je dirais urgents de la part du
gouvernement français
dans cette question il ya trois axes il
ya quand même
un axe humanitaire qui est kate qui
était déplorable en tout cas le rapport
de l' ong right and security
international
l ars y décrit une conduite des
conditions sanitaires indigne on peu cas
des enfants qui aujourd'hui mange dans
des poubelles les enfants qui sans
timmer d'ailleurs les enfants qui
meurent de diarrhée aiguë de 2,2
vraiment de quoi de de malnutrition
s'est établie ce sont des rapports qui
sont là qui décrivent des conditions de
fond français en syrie qui sont andy est
donc cet aspect humanitaire déjà
interpellent des parlementaires en ce
sens relevé déjà de plusieurs mois pour
réclamer le rapatriement de ses enfants
et de leur mère parce que ce sont aussi
des mères françaises pour celles qui
sont identifiés comme thème
titine nécessite un regard d'autant plus
que pour ce qui concerne les mères de
ses enfants elles sont identifiées elles
font l'objet de mandats d'arrêt
internationaux
pour beaucoup d'entre eux dont les
dossiers sont ouverts en france portée
par des confrères qui les défendent
d'ailleurs parmi ceux là ceux qui
justement sont aujourd'hui au nombre de
collectifs qui réclament le rapatriement
donc nous disons que ce sont des
personnes qui sont identifiés d'aider
les mères qui font l'objet pour la
plupart elles sont plusieurs dizaines
qui font l'objet de mandats d'arrêt
internationaux de telle sorte que des
procédures sont déjà couvertes en france
elles ont été placées sous mandat
d'arrêt par un juge français nous disons
donc il ya aucune raison de les
maintenir en syrie où elles sont à la
merci des dyades east où elles peuvent
justement constitué même un danger pour
notre beau pays justement détenir à
l'étranger justement vous parlez de 2
deux dangers danielle babin d'un côté il
ya cet appel à on l'a dit pour rapatrier
les femmes et enfants djihadistes qui
sont retenus en syrie mais de l'autre il
ya la crainte
de certains politiques de voir ces
personnes rentrer en france imprégné de
la doctrine islamiste radicale quels
risques réels
non bon dans la meuse où il ya des
procédures judiciaires qui sont ouvertes
il n'y a pas de risque ces personnes une
fois arrivés en france seront incarcérés
n'est ce pas le temps de la procédure
elle va être jumelles on doive être
entendu dans l'est la pauvre gars décidé
de se libérer et si elles sont libérées
derrière sk pendant un risque derrière
je pense que la france et l état de
droit on des personnes qui peut propres
mots tel danger pour le pays elles
seront sous contrôle en tout cas
l'incarcération est déjà la première
mesure qui ferait qu elles ne sont pas
laissés dans la nature et le temps de la
procédure judiciaire ces personnes
peuvent être sous contrôle n'est ce pas
du point de vue de la sécurité y a rien
à craindre parce que c'est des personnes
qui seront entre les mains de la justice
et au loin dans ces conditions là les
enfants reprend et seront mis sous bonne
garde les enfants peuvent être
accueillis par des personnes de
confiance au sein de la famille ou
encore par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
d'abord dans ce dossier je pense que
c'est d'abord l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant qui doit primer la france doit
respecter ses engagements internationaux
notamment la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant l'intérêt superbe
les règles internationales
par dos ça veut dire que la france viole
les règles internationales d'après ce
que vous dites avec bien sûr bien sûr
que dans ce cas si oui manifestement
parce que bon écoutez la crise syrienne
et date quand même de 2015 depuis que la
guerre a pris fin nous voyons des
familles françaises des enfants quelles
que soient les consoles lesquelles les
personnes se sont retrouvées sur eux sur
le théâtre de l'opération jihadiste en
syrie mais nous disons qu'à un moment
donné il y a des voix qui se lève et à
des commissions qui sont en prison parce
qu'ils sont contraints d'étudier la
question il ya des parlementaires qui se
sont saisis de la question en vue
d'interpeller la france dans le cadre du
respect de ses droits au plan
international le plafond subo fait tout
ce qui est de son pouvoir pour mettre
fin à cette situation qui est
particulièrement ending et est dit si
pour les enfants dont on leur décrit
fréquent des conditions de vie
inhumaines et saas est elle digne d'un
état de droit mais la france en tout cas
pour les adultes et plus
particulièrement pour les femmes la
france l'état estime que ces personnes
doivent être jugées là où les crimes ont
été commis
ceux là sont en cela son temps ces
personnes peuvent être jugés là où les
crimes ont été commis daccord du tous
poils de point de vue du droit cela se
tient aussi mais je dirais pour ce qui
concerne la situation des enfants
particulier les enfants dès lors qu'ils
ont été identifiés comme étant étant des
enfants français doivent être mis en
sécurité doivent être mis dans des
conditions il peut voir recevoir
l'éducation un traitement digne parce
que pour beaucoup d'enfants ils sont
malades il faut les extraire il est
notamment du théâtre des opérations dia
d'istres les mettre en sécurité les
traiter les confie à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance le taux de la procédure pour
ce qui concerne les marchés merci donné
le besoin si les deux questions ont ce
qu'il faut dissocier les deux questions
la question des enfants et la question
des parents merci daniel maman d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocate spécialisée en droit
des étrangers